CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW.
BUT FIRST MY OPEN.
IF YOU EVER HAD A QUESTION
WHETHER THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
DISTORTS, AND WHIPS UP AND
THROWS THINGS OUT OF FOCUSES
SPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, LOOK NO
FURTHER THAN CORONAVIRUS.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA, IT’S TIME TO BUY THE
FAMILY CEMETERY PLOT.
>> THE CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO BECOME A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A REALITY
SHOW.
>> THE RESPONSE TO THE COLD
FRONT IN THE UNITED STATES IS
BEING LED BY THE MOST
INCOMPETENT AND IGNORANT
PRESIDENT IN U.S. HISTORY.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHAT ELSE THE
DOWN SIDE OF THEIR DOOMSDAY
REPORTING?
THE DOWN SIDE IS PREDICTABLE.
WHEN PEOPLE ARE SCARED AND THEY
THINK IT’S JUST A QUESTION OF
TIME BEFORE THEY START DROPPING
LIKE FLIES, THEY GONE INTO
SURVIVAL MINNESOTA MODE.
THEY DON’T -- SURVIVAL MODE.
THEY TALK ABOUT TAKE THEIR
CHILDREN OUT OF SCHOOL,
EDUCATION SUFFERS.
THEY TALK ABOUT CANCELING MARCH
MADNESS AND COACHELLA.
AND THEY GO IN DEPRESSION MODE
BECAUSE THEIR QUALITY OF LIFE IS
OVER.
AND WHO BETTER TO TRUMP THE -- B
TRUMPET THAN CNN.
THE TOTAL LOSS OF 3,000 POINTS
OVER THE PAST WEEK ON THE DOW.
JUDGE JEANINE: YOU WANT TO FOCUS
ON THE DOW NOW?
WHERE WERE YOU WHEN THE DOW AND
THE S & P AND NASDAQ REPEATEDLY
REACHED RECORD HIGHS UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU WEREN’T INTERESTED THEN.
WHERE WERE YOU WHEN THE DOW
CLOSED AS A THE AT A RECORD
HIGH.
WHERE WERE YOU WHEN ANIMAL
SPIRITS WERE DRIVING THE ECONOMY
TO RECORD HEIGHTS.
OUR ECONOMY CAN SUSTAIN A
3,000-POINT DROP BECAUSE WE ARE
AT RECORD HIGHS.
JOB NUMBERS CAME OUT AND THEY
ARE BEYOND EXPECTATION.
LONG-TERM INTEREST RATES ARE
PLUNGING SO PEOPLE CAN
REFINANCE.
THOSE WHO NEED SUBSIDIES ARE
GOING TO GET THEM.
AND THE MEDIA COMPLAINS THERE
WAS A LACKLUSTER INITIAL
RESPONSE BY THE TRUMPED
MINISTRATION.
SAY WHAT?
LET’S START WITH THE FACT THAT
THE U.S. HAS ONE OF THE BEST
HEALTHCARE SYSTEMS IN THE WORLD.
JANUARY 31 THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION RESTRICTED ENTRY
INTO THIS COUNTRY FROM CHINA IN
AN EFFORT TO STEM THE OUTBREAK.
AMERICAN TRAVELERS WERE UNDER
QUARANTINE AS THE ADMINISTRATION
DECLARED A RARE HEALTH
EMERGENCY.
THE PRESIDENT DID THIS KNOWING
IT WOULD SEND SHOCKS THROUGH THE
STOCK MARKET, THAT IT WOULD
RATHER INDUSTRY BETWEEN THE
WORLD’S TWO LARGEST ECONOMICS.
HE IMMEDIATELY PUT TOGETHER THE
SMARTEST, MOST SOPHISTICATED
TEAM OF SCIENTISTS AND
HEALTHCARE OFFICIALS TO DEAL
WITH HIS DECLARES CORONAVIRUS
HEALTH EMERGENCY.
HE ASSIGNED TO VICE PRESIDENT
MIKE PENCE THE JOB OF ORGANIZING
A TEAM TO WORK WITH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
HIS EFFORTS HAVE BEEN NONSTOP.
THE POLITICAL CRITICISMS BY THE
LEFT LIKE THE GOVERNOR OF
WASHINGTON AND NEW YORK STATE
ARE NOTHING MORE THAN POLITICAL
GAMESMANSHIP THAT HAVE NO PLACE
IN THIS EFFORT.
THE EFFORT TO DEVELOP A VACCINE
AND MAKING TESTING KITS
AVAILABLE TO EVERY DOCTOR IN
THIS COUNTRY WITH A MINIMUM OF
$4 MILLION GOING TO EACH OF THE
50 STATES IS UNDERWAY.
WHAT TO DO?
IT’S A VIRUS LIKE THE FLU.
IT CAN BE MISTAKEN FOR THE FLU.
A SORE THROAT, A COUGH, A FEVER.
AND IT IS FLU SEASON.
YOU SAY BUT PEOPLE ARE DYING.
SADLY THAT’S TRUE.
AND NOT ONLY ARE CONDOLENCES IN
ORDER.
BUT WE OWE IT TO THEIR FAMILIES
AND ALL AMERICANS TO COUPLE WITH
A VACCINE.
LIKE THE FLU, TESTS FOR THE
CORONAVIRUS ARE BEING MADE
AVAILABLE TO EVERY STATE LAB.
POLITICAL TRIAL -- CLINICAL
TRIALS WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR THE VACCINE.
THEY ARE WORK VIGOROUSLY TO CUT
DOWN THE RED TAPE.
AND THE BEST AND BRIGHTEST AND
RESOLUTE ARE WORKING NONSTOP TO
CREATE THIS VACCINE.
THEY SAY THE MORTALITY RATE
FORWARD THE CORONAVIRUS IS
HIGHER THAN THE FLU.
CONSIDER WE HAVE A FLU VACCINE
BUT IN 2019, 16,000 AMERICANS
DIED FROM THE FLU.
IMAGINE IF WE DIDN’T HAVE THE
FLU VACCINE THE FLU WOULD BE A
PANDEMIC.
SO ALL THE TALK ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS BEING SO MUCH MORE
DEADLY DOESN’T REFLECT REALITY.
WITHOUT A VACCINE THE FLU WOULD
BE FAR MORE DEADLY.
NOW, WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THE
MORTALITY RATE IS MUCH HIGHER
AMONG ELDERLY ADULTS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE RISK
OF DYING IF INFECTED IS HIGHER.
WHICH MIGHT EXPLAIN WHEN WE SEE
CHILDREN ARE NOT REALLY AFFECTED
BY THE VIR.
BUT DR. FAUCI SAID THE RISK IS
GREAT IF YOU AS AN ELDERLY
PERSON HAVE SCENE UNDERLYING
CONDITION LIKE HEART DISEASE,
DIABETES OR PASS MA.
SMOKING IS ALSO A FACTOR PAP 50%
OF CHINESE MEN ARE SMOKERS.
>> PEOPLE DIE, THAT’S WHAT
HAPPENS IN LIFE.
THE BP OIL SPILL WAS GOING TO
END THE WORLD.
.
JUDGE JEANINE: WHAT TO DO?
WASH YOUR HANDS.
I KNOW EVERYONE THINKS THERE HAS
TO BE MORE TO THIS.
THE REASON YOU WASH YOUR HANDS
IS TO GET THE GERMS OFF.
THE REASON WHY YOU NEED TO GET
THE GERMS OFF BECAUSE YOU CAN
THEN TRANSFER THEM TO YOUR EYES,
NOSE AND MOUTH, RISKING
INFECTION TO YOUR RESPIRATORY
INFECTION.
YOU ARE LOOKING AT A CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL JOIN WAS LECTURING HOW
NOT TO TOUCH HER FACE.
AS WE REPEATEDLY PUTS HER
FINGERS IN HER MOUTH.
WHATEVER YOU HAVE TO DO, DON’T
TOUCH YOUR FACE.
GLOVES WON’T MATTER BECAUSE THE
VIRUS CAN LAST FOR HOURS ON THEM
AND SURFACES.
IF YOU NEED TO BORROW YOUR DOG’S
SHOCK COL ARE OR GO OUT -- SHOCK
COLLAR.
DON’T TOUCH YOU’RE FACE.
CLEAN SURFACES EVERY DAY LIKE
COUNTER TOPS AND DOOR NOBS.
THE SURGEON GENERAL SAID YOU
DON’T NEED A MASK UNLESS YOU ARE
SICK.
AND THERE IS NO NEED TO CLEAN
OUT THE STORE SHELVES.
AS THE WEATHER WARMS, LESS AND
LESS PEOPLE WILL GET SICK FROM
THE VIRUS.
IF YOU WANT TO COMPLAIN.
COMPLAIN ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE
RELY ON CHINA AND INDIA FOR
INGREDIENTS FOR SOME OF OUR
MEDICATION.
EVEN THE MEDS THEMSELVES.
LIKE NUCLEAR MEDICINE AND MOLLY
99, IT’S TIME TO MAKE AMERICA
FIRST THERE.
SO, MAYBE BILL MAHER HAS THE
RIGHT ATTITUDE.
STOP PANICKING, FEAR MORNING,
HIDING UNDER YOUR BED AND
FREAKING.
IN FACT, SNAP OUT OF IT.
AND WASH YOUR DAMN HANDS.
WASH THEM, THEN WASH THEM AGAIN.
THAT’S MY OPEN.